you have three lovely kids at home is
Thor their favorite superhero
one of them yes oh yeah one of them one
of my boys is loves it
the other two are like yeah yeah just
breasts really then we're tuning Hulk
team laughs yeah and I our team hope
actually Captain America was son oh yeah
Sasha my boy he were on set the other
day and Avengers you didn't run up to
Captain America but he doesn't do that
to anybody
what were you the god of again you've
been the Norse god of thunder for a
while now so I imagine you're very
familiar with the Nordic language you
must be of course yeah lonely so you got
to give me your best shot at some of
these really great Nordic see if you can
get that Wow tough will help googly blah
Heidi grindin dr4 else can you make it
sound like anyone gonna correct me and
tell me that's right a room I mean we're
gonna get a lot of emails about that
because it was perfect
take his word for it after all he has
played the mythical role on the big
screen six times since 2011 was this the
most fun it was I'm in the first film
that we made was was hugely exciting and
amazing and we built the character there
and then I did a few more after that and
it was there were all a lot of fun but I
just became a little sick of what I was
doing a little sort of became too
familiar you know and I felt like I had
built these these walls on what the
characters expectations were and what he
couldn't couldn't do and so this film we
just sort of broke the mold and and
threw anything out familiar anything was
familiar we just threw it out the window
tried something different and I think
there's a much more sivan predictable so
turning quality to the whole world we
know each other
is a friend from work is there more you
in Thor at this time around I think so
yeah that was the goal you know it's
quite hard to play yeah a stoic Stern
still hero you know bit dumb I don't
know just because it's it's not so much
in my nature you know this is this a lot
more this sort of looseness and that
sort of quality is definitely more of
Who I am and it's so much more fun you
know not kind of aiming for a target to
sort of get each day and just instead of
rolling the dice and saying out whatever
happens happens and let's have fun
smile and you know when we did had too
much fun and now he's having even more
fun filming the highly anticipated
Avengers infinity war alongside the
usual all-star cast but one thing that
will be missing is Thor's iconic hammer
which has been destroyed by Cate
Blanchett or Ragnarok when it comes to
infinity war what weapon will you be
wielding when you're fighting off you
know the bad guys of the cosmos you love
to see that's I can't get a better way
but there is there is something pretty
exciting coming make only the fans will
know and love and mix artifice
[Music]
you